PREVIOUSLY ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL"...
AFTER BATTLING DEHYDRATION,
DANIELLE BOUNCED BACK.
I LOVE YOUR BODY LANGUAGE
RIGHT NOW.
GORGEOUS.
AND AT THE PHOTO SHOOT,
SARA PLAYED COPYCAT.
I WANT TO START DOING A LITTLE
BIT OF THE THING
THAT JOANIE JUST DID.
♪♪♪
FURONDA SHOWED
HER PLAYFUL PERSONALITY.
(laughter)
BUT IT WASN'T ENOUGH
TO OUTSHINE HER COMPETITORS.
SHE LOOKS LIKE SHE
JUST DOESN'T QUITE GET IT.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
FOUR GIRLS REMAIN:
JOANIE, JADE,
SARA, AND DANIELLE.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ I WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪♪♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ I WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪♪♪
♪ YOU WANNA BE ON TOP ♪♪
I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO
LAST ELIMINATION.
FURONDA AND JADE,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
AND I'M, LIKE, BACK IN
MY OLD POSITION AGAIN.
BOTTOM TWO.
I DON'T BELONG THERE, MAN--
LIKE, WHAT IS GOING ON?
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT YOU
THAT'S JUST LIKE,
"I'LL CHANGE A LITTLE,
BUT I KNOW BEST."
JADE, YOU DON'T KNOW BEST.
I'VE SAID THAT A MILLION TIMES.
TYRA WAS SAYING THAT, BASICALLY,
I THINK I KNOW MORE
THAN THE JUDGES,
WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY CRAZY,
'CAUSE, I MEAN,
COME ON, NO.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY KEEP ON
GETTING THESE DIFFERENT
PERCEPTIONS OF ME.
WHOO!
SARA AND I ARE IN THE POOL, AND
WE JUST KIND OF CHILLING OUT.
ONE THING THAT, LIKE, REALLY
CONCERNS ME BEING IN
THE COMPETITION
IS MY SOUTHERN ACCENT.
THE ONE THING THAT THESE JUDGES
STRUGGLE WITH YOU IS THIS.
(southern accent)
THEY SAY IT EVERY WEEK,
EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
AND I'VE TOLD YOU A COUPLE
OF TIMES,
BUT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN IMPROVEMENT.
I TRY TO LISTEN TO MYSELF WHEN
I SPEAK, AND I THINK THAT'S
THE THING,
BECAUSE I SPEED TALK,
THAT MY WORDS JUST SEEM
REALLY JUMBLED TOGETHER.
SO I NEED TO JUST, LIKE,
START SPEAKING SLOWLY.
I GREW UP IN THE SOUTH
ALL MY LIFE.
LIKE, THAT'S PRETTY MUCH
ALL THAT I KNOW.
SO TO HEAR, YOU KNOW,
THE PANEL SAY THAT
THEY DON'T LIKE THE WAY I SPEAK,
IT'S KIND OF DIFFICULT FOR ME
TO UNDERSTAND.
'CAUSE, YOU CAN,
LIKE, YOU CAN SPEAK.
LIKE, WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
AND I TELL YOU, LIKE,
SAY SOMETHING.
- RIGHT, RIGHT.
- THEN YOU'RE FINE.
I'M A SOUTHERN COUNTRY GIRL,
YOU KNOW,
SO IT IS KIND OF HARD
FOR ME TO BREAK THAT ACCENT,
BUT I'M TRYING MY BEST.
IT JUST BLOWS ME AWAY-- THIS
WHOLE EXPERIENCE BLOWS ME AWAY.
I'M THE GIRL WHO GOT DISCOVERED
AT THE MALL.
SO, SARA, YOU DIDN'T HAVE
TO STAND IN THE LINE FOREVER
FOR THIS AUDITION.
WE FOUND YOU IN A MALL
AND CHASED YOU DOWN.
YEAH, THIS IS AS, YOU KNOW,
SURPRISING A SITUATION
AS I'VE BEEN IN.
SARA, SHE'S BEAUTIFUL, BUT I
JUST SEE IT AND I FEEL THAT THIS
REALLY ISN'T HER REAL PASSION
IN LIFE,
AND IT IS FOR-- FOR MYSELF
AND FOR DANIELLE AND FOR JADE.
DOES IT FRUSTRATE YOU
WHEN PEOPLE ARE, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
"SHE DIDN'T DESERVE IT,"
OR, "SHE DIDN'T WANT IT
"'CAUSE SHE HAD--
SHE, YOU KNOW,
GOT DISCOVERED IN A MALL."
DOES THAT, LIKE,
REALLY PISS YOU OFF?
IT FRUSTRATES ME,
'CAUSE WHEN THEY SAY THAT,
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE SAYING
THAT...
I'M NOT GONNA
PUT EVERYTHING INTO IT.
I'M JUST AS DESERVING,
AND I WANT IT JUST AS MUCH
AS EVERYONE ELSE,
AND, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER OR NOT
THEY BELIEVE THAT
IS UP TO THEM.
TYRA MAIL!
"DON'T WORRY ABOUT HOW,
JUST KNOW WHY.
GO SEE IF YOU
LEARNED ANYTHING."
- GO-SEE.
♪♪♪
WE ARRIVE AT THIS TEMPLE,
AND THIS IS
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL TEMPLE
I'VE SEEN UP CLOSE.
WELCOME TO THAILAND.
THIS IS THE TEMPLE OF DAWN,
AND MY NAME IS PICHITA.
I AM A FORMER MODEL, AND NOW
I'M DESIGNER IN BANGKOK.
TODAY I'M GOING TO TEACH YOU
SOME THAI CUSTOM.
WHEN YOU GO INTO THE HOUSE,
NORMALLY,
WE HAVE
TO TAKE OFF THE SHOES.
THAILAND MEAN THE COUNTRY OF
SMILE, SO PLEASE KEEP SMILING.
WHENEVER YOU GO,
THE PEOPLE WILL LIKE YOU.
I THINK EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
THAT LEARNING THE CULTURE
IS IMPORTANT,
BUT I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
IS TAKING IT
AS SERIOUSLY AS I AM.
I SET UP GO-SEES TODAY.
A GO-SEE IS WHEN YOU TAKE
YOUR PORTFOLIO TO A CLIENT
FOR POTENTIAL WORK,
AND PRETTY MUCH THEY DECIDE,
"YES, WE WANT YOU,"
OR, "NO, WE DON'T WANT
TO BOOK YOU FOR THIS JOB."
THE DESIGNER WILL JUDGE YOU
ON THAI SOCIAL CUSTOM,
YOUR GENERAL APPEARANCE,
YOUR MODEL BOOK,
AND YOUR RUNWAY WALK.
AND NOW I GOING TO GIVE YOU
A MAP AND MODEL BOOK.
AT THE END, PICHITA
GIVES US OUR PORTFOLIOS,
AND IT'S ACTUALLY
REALLY EXCITING.
JUST SEEING
EVERY SINGLE PICTURE
JUST REMINDS OF THAT DAY
THAT I TOOK IT, AND,
YOU KNOW, THINGS
I STILL NEED TO WORK ON.
YOU HAVE TO BE BACK
AT LAST LOCATION BY 4:30.
AND NOW, GOOD LUCK.
WE HAVE A TIME LIMIT,
AND WE HAVE TO BE BACK AT 4:30.
IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT,
SHE STRESSED,
TO BE BACK AT 4:30.
DON'T BE LATE.
ALL THE GIRLS WENT TO THE MARKET
TO BUY GIFTS FOR THE GO-SEES.
IT WAS REALLY HECTIC
IN THE MARKET.
SOON AS I WALKED IN, IT'S LIKE,
STUFF EVERYWHERE.
I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT ANGLE TO START AT.
WHAT IS YOUR CHEAPEST THING
ON THIS TABLE?
HOW MUCH?
FOR ONE?
I GOT MANY ELEPHANTS
FOR MY GO-SEES.
I WAS KIND OF THINKING THAT THEY
WOULD APPRECIATE THE ELEPHANT,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THE ELEPHANT
IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT IN THAILAND.
WHAT ABOUT THIS ONE?
WOULD YOU GIVE ME
FIVE FOR 1,000?
THANK YOU.
OH, MY GOD.
I'M AN IDIOT.
WHERE IS MY BOOK?
IN THIS COMPETITION,
IF YOU MESS UP,
THEN YOU DON'T
GET ANOTHER CHANCE,
SO I REALLY NEED
TO STEP IT UP.
CLOSE ONE.
(laughs)
THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO START.
(speaks Thai)
AFTER I GET MY GIFT, I RUSH OUT
TO GET IN MY TUK-TUK.
TUK-TUKS ARE,
LIKE, MINIATURE CABS,
BUT THEY'RE ALL OPEN
ON THE SIDES.
RIGHT HERE.
WE GO?
IF IT WAS UP TO ME, I WOULDN'T
HAVE CHOSE TO RIDE IN A TUTU.
HOO-HOO.
POO-POO.
TUT-TUT.
HOOPDIE, OKAY?
BECAUSE I WOULD HAVE
HAD SOMETHING WITH WINDOWS,
SOMETHING WITH DOORS.
I'VE NEVER BEEN ON A GO-SEE
BEFORE IN MY LIFE, SO THE FACT
THAT WE'RE DOING THEM
IN A DIFFERENT COUNTRY,
AND IN THE COURSE OF ABOUT
FOUR HOURS,
IT KIND OF PUTS
A LITTLE MORE PRESSURE ON.
RIGHT HERE.
I'M GONNA TRY--
I'M NOT GOOD WITH DIRECTIONS.
I CANNOT READ MAPS.
PERSONALLY, I'M TERRIFIED,
BECAUSE I HAVE A FEELING
I'M GONNA LOOK UP AND I'M
GONNA SEE A SIGN THAT SAYS,
"WELCOME TO KOREA."
DO YOU KNOW
WHERE WE'RE GOING?
OKAY, LET'S GO.
LET'S MOVE!
YAY!
(speaks Thai)
GOOD, HOW ARE YOU?
I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT
THAT I'LL BE ABLE TO KEEP
THE THAI SOCIAL CUSTOMS,
LIKE, IN MIND,
WHILE I'M GOING
TO THE GO-SEES.
BUT, I MEAN, IT'S ONE THING TO,
LIKE, KNOW IT IN YOUR HEAD,
AND THEN IT'S ANOTHER THING,
LIKE, IN THE MOMENT,
TO KIND OF DO IT.
THIS IS FOR YOU.
OH, WOW, THANK YOU.
THIS IS A NICE SURPRISE.
I LOVE SARA'S GIFT.
I THOUGHT SHE DID A REALLY GOOD
JOB IN CHOOSING
A THAI GIFT FOR A THAI PERSON.
LET ME HAVE A LOOK
AT YOUR BOOK.
HAVE YOU HAD MUCH EXPERIENCE,
OR ARE YOU JUST STARTING OUT?
- I'M JUST STARTING OUT.
- OKAY.
22 IS QUITE OLD TO START OUT,
ISN'T IT?
THE NERVES IN GENERAL OF THIS
BEING MY FIRST EXPERIENCE
MADE ME REALLY
KIND OF STIFF.
JUST SHOW ME
A RELAXED SPA LOOK WALK.
OKAY, MAYBE WALK LESS LIKE--
MORE RELAXED.
SHE'S A LITTLE BIT STIFF FOR ME,
JUST IN HER WAY SHE WALKED.
- YOU'RE TOO TALL.
- (laughs)
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
- OKAY?
(both speaking Thai)
CHALLENGE RULES TODAY ARE,
YOU NOW, JUST MANAGE YOUR TIME.
IT'S ALL YOU, BUT BE BACK AT
THE HOTEL BY 4:30, SO IT'LL BE--
IT'S GONNA BE KIND OF HARD.
HI.
(speaks Thai)
MY NAME IS JOANIE.
THESE ARE FOR YOU.
- MY NAME IS DISAYA.
- DISAYA?
OH, OKAY.
IT WAS WEIRD, BUT I LIKED IT
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
NO ONE REALLY SAW YOUR FACE
AND HOW DUMB YOUR FACE LOOKED.
JADE SHOWED UP
AT MY GO-SEE.
I JUST FEEL LIKE IF JADE
SEES HOW WELL WE INTERACTED
THAT SHE MIGHT TRY TO,
LIKE, COPY ME.
I DON'T KNOW IF LINGERIE
IS REALLY JOANIE'S MARKET.
- NICE TO MEET YOU.
- NICE TO MEET YOU, TOO.
I DON'T THINK JOANIE
HAS A LINGERIE BODY AT ALL.
I THINK I DO.
I WORE A BEAUTIFUL LINGERIE
PIECE, AND I WAS A CHIPMUNK.
IT WAS KIND OF HARD
SEEING OUT OF IT,
BUT I THINK
I HELD IT TOGETHER.
I LIKE JADE'S LOOK.
THE ONLY THING IS THAT SHE
WASN'T VERY, YOU KNOW, SMILEY.
SHE'S--
LOOK A BIT MOODY TO ME.
(speaks Thai)
I'M KIND OF GUESSING
WHAT TIME IT IS.
AS I'M GOING TO MY GO-SEES,
I'M KIND OF SEEING IF THERE'S
SOMEBODY BEFORE ME,
PACING MYSELF,
JUST CALCULATING IN MY MIND.
- (speaks Thai)
- ELEPHANT.
- WOW.
I WALK INSIDE,
THE SHOES ARE STILL ON.
MY FIRST GO-SEE HAS TO TELL ME
TO TAKE MY SHOES OFF.
YES.
THANK YOU.
AT LEAST MY SOUTHERN ACCENT
DOESN'T MATTER FOR MY GO-SEES.
GENTLE?
I REALLY NEED TO DO WELL
IN THE CHALLENGE
AND PROVE THAT
I WANT TO BE HERE.
I ROLL UP TO MY NEXT CASTING,
AND AS SOON AS I WALKED IN,
I SAW SARA'S TALL ASS.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE REALLY
IMPRESSED THE DESIGNER BECAUSE
SHE SEEMED A LITTLE BIT
TENSE WALKING.
(laughs)
IT WAS A LITTLE INTIMIDATING
WHEN SHE
WALKED IN THE DOOR.
I'M NOT SURE IF I HAVE ENOUGH
TIME TO GET BACK AT 4:30
TO OUR FINAL DESTINATION.
GOOD.
I THINK I DID PRETTY WELL.
I LOVE IT.
I'M HAVING A GOOD TIME.
IT'S HOT OUTSIDE,
IT'S HUMID.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT DOES
TO A BLACK GIRL'S HEAD?
DANIELLE, I REALLY LIKED HER,
ACTUALLY.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS
REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
I LIKED HER ATTITUDE.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHO'S GONNA WIN.
LIKE, I HAVEN'T
SEEN THE OTHER GIRLS
OR TALKED TO 'EM,
SO, YOU KNOW,
WE'LL SEE
WHEN EVERYBODY MEETS UP.
HOTEL.
- HUH?
- RIGHT HERE.
- HOTEL.
HOTEL, FAST.
(speaks Thai)
GOT TO GO.
(driver speaking Thai)
HOTEL...
YOU UNDERSTAND ME?
RIGHT THERE.
DO NOT PASS GO,
DO NOT COLLECT $200.
HOTEL.
SO I FIGURED I WOULD HAVE
PLENTY OF TIME TO BE BACK,
BUT THE TRAFFIC HERE
IS UNBELIEVABLE.
WILL WE MAKE IT BY 4:30?
AY-YI-YI-YI-YI.
WE'RE GONNA BE LATE.
LATE, LATE, LATE,
LATE, LATE.
♪♪♪
HELLO.
WE GET BACK AFTER THE GO-SEES
TO SEE PICHITA,
AND YOU CAN TELL
SHE'S PRETTY ANGRY.
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO BE BACK
BY 4:30.
I AM SO SORRY.
I'M LATE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS,
TO ME, SEEING ALL THE DESIGNERS.
THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR BEAUTIFUL FLOWERS.
I KNOW WE HAVE TO BE BACK
ON TIME AT 4:30,
BUT THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO ME.
(speaking Thai)
JADE IS AN HOUR
AND TEN MINUTES LATE.
(door creaks)
WHEN JADE WALKED INTO THIS ROOM,
LET ME TELL YOU,
SHE HAD SOME GLASSES ON,
TRYING TO BE INCOGNITO.
OH, MY GOD,
IT WAS HILARIOUS.
ALL THE GIRLS ARE LOOKING AT ME
LIKE...
AND I'M LIKE,
"BITCHES, PLEASE, OKAY?
RELAX YOURSELF."
ALL I GOT TO SAY
TO THAT DESIGNER IS,
"YOU TRY TRAVELING AROUND
IN A TUK-TUK WITH NO DOORS,
"HUMID OUTSIDE AND HOT,
AND SEE HOW YOUR APPEARANCE LOOK
BY THE END OF THE DAY."
I WISH SHE WOULD HAVE SAID,
"JADE REALLY HAS SUPERMODEL
STATUS TALENTS."
YOU KNOW?
I WANT TO HEAR THAT.
I'M SO SORRY.
GOOD LUCK AND GOOD-BYE.
THAT'S LIKE TAKING A KID
TO A CANDY STORE
AND SAYING,
"YOU CAN'T HAVE THE CANDY."
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
SHUT YOUR MOUTH.
OH, MY GOSH.
SHUT YOUR MOUTH AND SAY
IT AIN'T SO.
YOU GOT THE BRAS, TOO.
I AIN'T GOT NOTHING.
I MEAN, YOU WOULD HAVE
HAD THE BRAS.
SHUT UP.
PLEASE PUNCH ME IN THE FACE.
BAM.
THAT SUCKS FOR DANIELLE.
I FEEL VERY BAD FOR HER.
TYRA MAIL.
"DOES THIS COMPETITION
EVER GET SO DIFFICULT
THAT YOU JUST
WANT TO SAY"...
(laughing)
I'M LIKE, WHAT ARE WE
ABOUT TO BE DOING?
BUT, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
PRONOUNCED THE F-WORD,
IT'S ACTUALLY "POO-KET,"
AND SARA HAS A BOOK ON THAILAND,
SO SHE WENT AND LOOKED UP
"PHUKET."
PHUKET PROVINCE.
YEP.
- DIVING AND SNORKELING.
- DIVING AND SNORKELING!
- THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY?
- YEAH!
WE GOING TO THE OCEAN,
BREAK IT DOWN.
WE GOING TO THE OCEAN.
WE'RE HEADED TO PHUKET,
AND THAT IS, LIKE, THE BEST
TROPICAL LOCATION EVER.
IT'S LIKE THE MIAMI BEACH,
RIO DE JANEIRO OF ASIA.
WHEN WE ARRIVE
AT THE AIRPORT,
I'M LIKE A LITTLE KID
ON CHRISTMAS.
LIKE, I WANT TO GET THERE.
I WAS LIKE, "OH, MY GOD,
WE'RE GOING TO PARADISE."
I THINK THAT I HAD A REALLY
BAD DAY ON THE GO-SEES,
BUT HERE IN PHUKET,
IT'S LIKE,
ALL THE STRESSES OF
THE COMPETITION AND EVERYTHING
JUST KIND OF DISAPPEAR,
AT LEAST FOR THE TIME BEING.
JADE DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT ANYTHING
AS LONG AS SHE'S
GOING TO THE OCEAN.
Y'ALL KNOW I'VE BEEN DYING
TO GO TO THE OCEAN.
LIKE, THE WATER AND JADE,
WE MIX, YOU KNOW?
THAT'S JUST...
I LOVE IT.
HOME SWEET HOME.
HOLY COW.
WE GET TO OUR VILLA WHERE
WE'RE GONNA BE STAYING.
WE GET INSIDE,
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
WOW.
IT'S GORGEOUS.
A TROPICAL PARADISE.
IT'S JUST GORGEOUS.
YOU CAN SEE THE OCEAN
FROM HERE.
- OH, IT'S GONNA BE SO PRETTY.
- WOW.
- THIS IS AWESOME.
- IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S THE MOST BEAUTIFUL PLACE
I HAVE EVER BEEN IN MY LIFE,
AND I DON'T
EVER WANT TO LEAVE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS IS GONNA BE
OVER IN A WEEK.
BACK TO, LIKE, REAL LIFE.
WITH SARA,
THIS IS HER FIRST TIME EVER
DOING ANY TYPE
OF MODELING.
IT'S ALL VERY NEW TO HER.
WHAT A RIDE.
EVERYTHING HERE IS WILD.
BEYOND MY WILDEST DREAMS,
MAN.
I REALLY NEED TO SHOW HOW MUCH
I DO WANT IT AND HOW, YOU KNOW,
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT JUST
FELL INTO MY LAP.
EVERYTHING HAPPENS
FOR A REASON.
'CAUSE I WOULD NOT
BE HERE RIGHT NOW.
IT'S CRAZY FOR ME TO REALIZE
THAT I'M IN THE FINAL FOUR.
YOU GUYS WANT TO EAT INSIDE
OR OUTSIDE?
EAT OUTSIDE.
I FEEL, LIKE, VERY,
VERY ANNOYED WITH SARA,
BECAUSE I REALLY FEEL LIKE
THIS IS NOT HER FIRST CHOICE.
THIS ISN'T HER PASSION.
SHE WAS THIS CLOSE
TO BEING A LAWYER
AND HAD A CAREER
SET OUT FOR HER.
IF SHE HADN'T BEEN PICKED OUT
IN A MALL,
SHE WOULDN'T BE HERE.
I FEEL LIKE
A BITCH.
BUT I'M JUST LIKE...
BUT I'M LIKE, THIS IS WHAT
IT COMES DOWN TO.
THIS IS COMPETING
FOR SOMETHING THAT'S, LIKE,
YOU'RE GONNA BE
LIVING WITH
THE REST OF YOUR LIFE,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I CAN'T FOCUS ON HER SITUATION.
I GOTTA- I HAVE TO DO ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
AND SO...
WORKSHOP AND KEEP GOING.
THE REASON WHY IT HIT ME NOW
IS BECAUSE, LIKE,
SHE COPIES OFF OF ME.
I WANT TO START DOING
A LITTLE BIT OF THE THING
THAT JOANIE JUST DID.
I'M JUST GONNA START DOING
THINGS WRONG ON PURPOSE,
- MAYBE SHE...
- (laughing)
(laughs)
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
COMPETITION, LIKE,
I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE
SHE SHOULD BE HERE ANYMORE.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL!
AND IT CAME OUT
OF THIS COCONUT.
"THE COMPETITION
IS GETTING DIRTY.
NOW IT'S TIME
TO TAKE A BATH."
RUNNING WATERFALLS.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK--
CLEAN, WATERFALLS.
WHAT ARE WE FIXIN'
TO BE DOING?
IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW,
THE TYRA MAILS KIND OF GIVE YOU
LITTLE CLUES AND HINTS
AS TO WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE DOING.
WE SHOULD WAIT
AND SEE TOMORROW.
HELLO.
HOW ARE YOU?
GOOD, HOW ARE YOU?
- HUG.
- OKAY.
Y'ALL LOOK SO PRETTY.
THANK YOU.
JUST CUTE ON YOUR OWN,
JUST FOR NO REASON.
WELL, WE JUST LIKE TO SIT UP
AND CHILL, BE CHILL.
WE WAKE UP, AND I SEE
TYRA BANKS, AND I'M LIKE,
"TYRA IS IN OUR HUT."
THIS IS BEAUTIFUL.
I WANTED TO TALK TO YOU ALL
ABOUT WHERE YOU ARE.
LOOK AT THIS PLACE,
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
THIS IS PARADISE.
BUT OF COURSE, WE KNOW
THERE'S A HISTORY HERE.
THAT HISTORY WAS DECEMBER 26TH,
2004, THE DAY AFTER CHRISTMAS.
THE TSUNAMI HIT PHUKET,
AND IT DEVASTATED THIS ISLAND,
AND ALMOST 6,000 PEOPLE DIED.
WITH THE TSUNAMI, IN TOTAL,
IT AFFECTED 13 COUNTRIES,
ABOUT A QUARTER OF A MILLION
PEOPLE DEAD.
THAT WAS THE DEATH TOLL.
AS TYRA IS TALKING, ALL I CAN
HELP THINK ABOUT IS, LIKE,
THE PEOPLE
WHO LOST LOVED ONES.
AS A MODEL, YOU'RE GONNA TRAVEL
TO THE MOST BEAUTIFUL PLACES,
BUT EVERY ISLAND,
EVERY COUNTRY HAS A STORY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RESPECT
THE CULTURE
AND TO RESPECT THE HISTORY.
IT WAS VERY EMOTIONAL FOR ME,
BUT I'M A SOLDIER, YOU KNOW,
AND I HELD IT TOGETHER.
BUT I REALLY, YOU KNOW,
I THOUGHT ABOUT IT INSIDE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT
BEING SAD TODAY.
IT'S ABOUT
CELEBRATING THE FACT
THAT THIS BEAUTIFUL PROVINCE
IS REBUILT.
IT'S A SAFE PLACE, AND IT'S
A BEAUTIFUL PLACE, ALL RIGHT?
YOU KNOW WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO
WITH YOU GUYS NOW
IS TO HAVE
A LITTLE MOMENT OF SILENCE
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
LOST THEIR LIVES,
THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE INJURED,
AND THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATED BY THE TSUNAMI.
OKAY. ALL RIGHTY,
GOOD LUCK TONIGHT.
- THANK YOU.
- WELCOME.
(indistinct chatter)
ALL RIGHTY.
OKAY, I'LL SEE YOU GUYS
LATER, OKAY?
- OKAY.
- BYE.
BYE.
EVEN THOUGH PHUKET IS BUILT,
AND IT'S LIKE YOU WOULD
HAVE NEVER
KNOWN THE TSUNAMI
CAME THROUGH,
IT ACTUALLY DID HAPPEN.
IT'S JUST, LIKE, REALLY--
IT'S REALLY AFFECTING ME, 'CAUSE
I'M LIKE, PEOPLE DIED HERE.
LIFE IS SO SHORT, I MEAN,
ONE DAY YOU'RE HERE,
AND THE NEXT DAY YOU'RE NOT.
LIKE, WE'RE BASICALLY
A MOMENT,
LIKE, FROM THE NEWS, WHEN THEY
SHOWED ALL THE DEVASTATION
AND YOU'RE SEEING
ALL THE STORIES.
IT'S CRAZY TO JUST BE, LIKE,
FEET AWAY FROM THE WATER
THAT CAUSED ALL THE DEVASTATION,
YOU KNOW?
NO MATTER WHAT HAD BEEN
GOING ON BETWEEN US ALL,
I THINK, AT THAT MOMENT,
THE TSUNAMI,
IT REALLY DID JUST KIND OF
MAKE ALL THOSE THINGS
DISAPPEAR FOR A MINUTE.
♪♪♪
WELCOME TO PARADISE!
TODAY'S SHOOT IS FOR
"ELLEgirl" MAGAZINE,
AND AMP'D MOBILE,
WHO'S AMERICA'S FIRST WIRELESS
ENTERTAINMENT PROVIDER,
AND THE CLIENTS ARE HERE.
SO IT'S A REAL JOB.
JAY TELLS US THAT THE CLIENTS
ARE HERE.
I JUST FEEL REALLY INTIMIDATED
AND A LOT OF PRESSURE,
'CAUSE I WANT TO DO WELL.
THE SPREAD THAT YOU GIRLS SHOOT
TODAY ON THIS BEACH
IS GONNA BE A REAL SPREAD
IN "ELLE girl" MAGAZINE.
SHUT YOUR MOUTH
AND SAY IT AIN'T SO!
IT IS SO!
AND AMP'D MOBILE USERS
CAN DOWNLOAD THE PHOTOS
TO THEIR CELL PHONES.
I GOT OP SWIMWEAR FOR YOU GIRLS
TO BE WEARING,
SO I'M GONNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO YOUR TWO CLIENTS TODAY.
I HAVE CHRISTIE,
WHO'S THE PROMOTIONS DIRECTOR
FROM "ELLEgirl" MAGAZINE,
AND ERIC, THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
FROM OP SWIMWEAR.
ALL RIGHT?
I'M LOOKING AT THE WATER,
AND I'M KNOWING THAT THIS WATER
A YEAR AGO, LIKE,
DESTROYED EVERYTHING
THAT WE'RE STANDING ON.
IT WAS REALLY AFFECTING ME.
HEY, GIRLS, COME ON
DOWN HERE.
I HAVE TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY.
I HAD TO GET SOMEBODY
WHO HAS A DISCERNING EYE.
A LITTLE OPINIONATED--
A TOUGH CRITIC.
YOU PROBABLY ALL KNOW HIM.
MR. NIGEL BARKER.
- WHOO!
- LADIES.
(all cheering)
HOW ARE YOU?
I WAS LIKE, AHH!
I WAS SO HAPPY, EVEN THOUGH
HE DOES INTIMIDATE ME.
THAT'S ONE PERSON
THAT DOES INTIMIDATE ME.
REMEMBER, THIS MAN KNOWS
ALL YOUR STRENGTHS
AND ALL YOUR WEAKNESSES.
I'M GONNA TAKE
NO PRISONERS TODAY.
START HERE, THEN WE MOVE.
THAT'S HOW REAL
FASHION STORIES WORK.
IT'S NOT JUST
THE ONE POSITION.
I WANT YOU TO REALLY MODEL.
THIS IS THE FINAL FOUR,
AND THIS IS WHERE WE REALLY
HAVE TO SHINE.
NOT ONLY THAT, BUT NIGEL
IS YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER.
- ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
- FINALLY.
IT LOOKS PRETTY DIFFICULT
'CAUSE THE WAVES ARE REALLY,
REALLY ROUGH TODAY,
SO THAT'S MAKING IT
REALLY DIFFICULT
TO SHOOT IN THE WATER,
'CAUSE THE WAVES ARE,
LIKE, PUSHING YOU.
THIS IS THE GLAMOROUS
SIDE OF MODELING.
EVERYONE THINKS
A BEACH IS WONDERFUL.
IT'S NOT.
YOU'RE SOAKING WET AND, LIKE,
YOU HAVE NO MAKE-UP ON,
BUT YOU STILL HAVE TO TRY
TO BE CUTE AND LOOK NICE.
JOANIE DID VERY WELL.
YOU KNOW, THE ENVIRONMENT
MAY LOOK FANTASTIC IN A PICTURE,
BUT YOU DON'T REALIZE SOMETIMES,
THE GIRL WAS FREEZING,
YOU KNOW, AND SHE MANAGED
TO BE GLOWING AND WARM.
OKAY, WE GOT IT.
- AWW!
- IT'S GOOD TO BE A JUDGE.
IT'S A LOT OF WORK.
WE'RE DEALING WITH
THE ELEMENTS AND THE WIND.
DON'T LET THE STRUGGLE
SHOW ON YOUR FACE.
WE'RE GONNA START YOU OFF
ON THE ROCKS,
'CAUSE THEY'RE NICE AND HARD,
AND THEN THE WAVES
ARE BEATING YOU DOWN.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS...
LET'S DO THIS.
THERE WERE SO MANY KIND OF
STRESSFUL ASPECTS TO THE SHOOT,
YOU KNOW, HAVING THE "ELLEgirl"
REP THERE, THE OP REP.
YOU KNOW, NIGEL, WHO I'M
COMPLETELY INTIMIDATED BY.
RELAX THE FACE
A LITTLE BIT.
NOT TOO "MODELLY."
THERE YOU GO.
IT WAS A BIT CHALLENGING
WHEN SARA'S FACIAL EXPRESSIONS
IN THE CAMERA
WEREN'T CONNECTING,
NECESSARILY, WITH THE SHOT.
MAYBE PUT YOUR HANDS
THROUGH YOUR HAIR
AND JUST MESS IT UP
A BIT FOR ME.
I THINK A GOOD MODEL HAS TO BE
COMFORTABLE WITH THEMSELVES,
AND SARA STILL, EVEN THOUGH WE
SAID TIME AND TIME AGAIN,
"RELAX, RELAX, RELAX,"
THE FACE WAS...
NOT SO OPEN--
A LITTLE LESS WITH THE LEGS.
I DON'T THINK SARA
WAS REALLY COMFORTABLE
WITH WHAT SHE WAS DOING.
SEE, IT'S NOT AS EASY
AS IT LOOKS, IS IT?
YOUR ARM UP LIKE THAT.
BRING YOUR OTHER ARM UP,
TOO,
AND JUST HAVE
A LITTLE SMALL MOMENT.
AND I CAN COME IN,
BUT... FOR YOUR FACE?
JUST RELAX IT.
NICE.
(Jay)
THAT'S BETTER, SARA.
MUCH BETTER, SARA.
COME IN CLOSER
WITH YOUR OTHER LEG.
I THINK THAT I KIND OF
RECENTERED MYSELF
AND REFOCUSED,
AND I DID A LOT BETTER.
IT WAS REALLY VERY PRETTY,
THE LAST ONE.
GOOD.
I'M JUST
AS DESERVING TO BE HERE
AS EVERY OTHER GIRL
THAT IS HERE.
- HEY, BUDDY.
- HEY.
SO, NIGEL, HERE'S WHAT YOUR
PICTURE LOOKS LIKE
IN THE APP, THE PHONE.
EVERYONE'S GOING
TO HAVE THE CHANCE
TO DOWNLOAD THESE IMAGES
TO THEIR PHONE.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
- I THINK--
- IT LOOKS GOOD, RIGHT?
IT LOOKS REALLY GOOD--
REALLY WORKS ON THE PHONE.
THE BLACK SURROUNDING REALLY
MAKES THE PICTURE POP.
I'D DEFINITELY LIKE TO,
YOU KNOW,
DO BATHING SUIT SHOTS
ALL MY LIFE-- I WOULD DO IT.
GIRL, YOU GOT THE BODY.
♪♪♪
I GOT ON THE BOAT.
MAN, LET ME TELL YOU.
I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS
BECAUSE THE BOAT WAS SHAKING.
I THINK SHE SHOULD
COME OFF THERE.
I JUST WENT UP THERE,
AND I WAS JUST LIKE,
"LET'S ROCK.
LET'S DO THIS.
I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS DAY--
LET'S DO IT!"
THAT'S NICE, BEAUTIFUL,
LIKE THAT-- HOLD THAT.
A GIRL THAT TAKES RISKS.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES
THAT PAYS OFF.
AND IT DID TODAY FOR JADE.
SHE WON ME OVER.
SHE MODELED.
I HAVE BEEN WAITING
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOOT WITH NIGEL, MAN.
HE MAKES PEOPLE FIERCE.
HOW YOU DOING?
- GOOD, HOW ARE YOU?
- GOOD.
SO ENJOY IT.
I THINK THE THING IS
IS TO BE CONFIDENTLY POSITIVE.
HAVE, LIKE, HAPPY THOUGHTS
TO YOURSELF.
♪♪♪
PEOPLE ACTUALLY DIED WHERE
I'M STANDING, AND IT'S LIKE,
IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO GET PAST THAT,
BECAUSE I AM A REALLY,
REALLY COMPASSIONATE PERSON.
I ALWAYS FIND
IN THESE SITUATIONS,
WHEN IT IS A LITTLE
DIFFICULT,
THINK OF ALL THE GOOD
THINGS THAT YOU'VE GOT
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT,
LIKE, THE--
THE WATER'S WARM,
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
ALL THOSE THINGS
ARE IN YOUR FAVOR, RIGHT?
AS OPPOSED TO, LIKE,
ALL THE THINGS THAT AREN'T
IN YOUR FAVOR.
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT
COULD GET YOU DOWN,
AND THAT'LL SHOW
IN YOUR EYES.
YOUR EYES UP TO ME, SWEETIE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE'S
TOO MANY TIMES WHERE DANIELLE
IS TOO CONSCIOUS
OF HER SURROUNDINGS,
AND THAT'S WHERE
IT ALL FALLS APART.
A LITTLE LESS.
HOLD THIS FOR ME.
WHAT WE WANT
IS JUST NATURAL BEAUTY.
THIS IS "ELLE," "ELLEgirl."
YOU HAVE TO THINK,
DIFFERENT CLIENTS,
DIFFERENT WAY OF MODELING.
SO LESS OF THIS AND MORE
JUST NATURAL, SMILE.
AND JUST--
YEAH, ALL THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
EVEN WHEN YOU PUT YOUR ARM UP,
YOU CAN DO THAT, BUT NOT...
BEAUTIFUL, DANIELLE.
RIGHT, LOOK AT ME--
I'M OVER HERE.
MAKE THE LEGS PRETTIER.
I WAS FRUSTRATED WITH MYSELF,
AND I'M MY OWN WORST CRITIC,
SO, YOU KNOW, I'M REALLY DOWN
ON MYSELF TODAY ABOUT THAT.
WOW, LOOK AT THAT.
IT LOOKS GREAT.
IF I SAY SO MYSELF...
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
BON VOYAGE.
NOT ONLY ARE WE LEAVING
PARADISE, WE'RE LEAVING PARADISE
FOR A STRESSFUL ELIMINATION.
THAT'S THE NATURE
OF THIS COMPETITION.
(airplane landing)
AND WE'RE BACK.
TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY THREE
WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
ELIMINATION SUCKS,
BUT IT'S REALITY.
AND THEN THERE WERE THREE.
AND THEN
THERE WERE THREE.
BUMMER FOR ONE OF US.
IT'S, YOU KNOW, IT'S DEFINITELY
GONNA BE A STRESSFUL DAY.
HONESTLY, I'M KIND OF
NERVOUS ABOUT MY PHOTO,
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE,
'CAUSE I CANNOT FOCUS
IN PHUKET.
AND FURTHERMORE,
EVERY TIME I OPEN MY MOUTH,
THE JUDGES HATE IT.
SO, TO THE OTHER GIRLS,
IF YOU THINK
I'M A DEFINITE PICK TO GO HOME
BECAUSE I HAVE
A SOUTHERN ACCENT,
I LOVE FOR YOU TO DOUBT ME,
'CAUSE I GET TO PROVE MYSELF.
'CAUSE WHEN I SHOW UP
AND SHOW OUT, IT'S A WRAP.
♪♪♪
(camera shutter clicks)
WELCOME, LADIES.
I HOPE THAILAND
HAS TREATED YOU WELL.
YOU'VE BEEN ALL OVER
THIS COUNTRY, HAVEN'T YOU?
BANGKOK AND PHUKET
AND BANGKOK AGAIN.
THAT'S HOW THE REAL MODELS
DO IT.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME
TO TAKE FOUR AND MAKE THREE.
OF COURSE, WE HAVE
SOME FABULOUS PRIZES.
THE FIRST
IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH TOP INTERNATIONAL MODELING
MANAGEMENT COMPANY FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
SHOT BY WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND HERE'S OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS THE NOTED FASHION
PHOTOGRAPHER NIGEL BARKER.
HEY, LADIES.
LEGENDARY DIVA RUNWAY COACH,
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
LIVING LEGEND AND ICON,
TWIGGY, AND DISAYA.
DISAYA IS THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
OF BOUDOIR.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR YOUR
INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE'LL DETERMINE WHICH OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
SO THIS WEEK,
YOU HAD GO-SEES,
AND GO-SEES ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT A MODEL
HAS TO DO TO GET A JOB.
ONE THING THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AT A GO-SEE
IS YOUR PHOTO, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT YOU LEAVE BEHIND.
POLAROIDS ARE BECOMING
THE IN-THING WITH RETOUCHING,
AS IT'S SUCH A FOREFRONT
IN PHOTOGRAPHY
THAT NO ONE CAN TRUST
WHAT THEY SEE HALF THE TIME.
EVERYONE TAKES POLAROIDS,
SO THEY GET THE REAL YOU.
ME IN PERSON IN MY PICTURES,
I GOT TWO BOOTIES.
I GOT MY REAL BOOTY, AND THEN
I GOT MY BOOTY IN PICTURES.
THIS IS MY REAL BOOTY.
YES, PLEASE, EXPLAIN.
THIS IS MY BOOTY IN PICTURES.
(laughter)
OKAY.
YOU DID POLAROIDS
AT YOUR GO-SEES,
SO THAT'S YOUR
JUDGING TEST TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE HOW YOU LOOK,
AND DANIELLE, YOU'RE FIRST.
ALL RIGHT, DANIELLE,
SO YOU HAD TO GO TO GO-SEES,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT
IN YOUR NORMAL CLOTHES.
(Nigel)
IT LOOKS OKAY.
IT DOESN'T LOOK GREAT.
IT DOESN'T LOOK BAD.
IT'S A REPRESENTATION,
BUT IT'S NOT AMAZING.
HERE'S YOUR SHOT WITH
THE DESIGNER'S CLOTHES ON.
YOU'VE GOT A GREAT FACE,
BUT I WOULDN'T PICK THAT OUT
AS SOMEBODY THAT I WOULD
PARTICULARLY CALL BACK.
DANIELLE, WERE YOU COMFORTABLE
IN THIS GARMENT?
YES, I WAS
VERY COMFORTABLE.
I THINK BEING IN A TUK-TUK
OR A PUT-PUT,
WHATEVER IT'S CALLED,
AND I WAS HOT,
I LET THAT AFFECT ME, AND--
BUT YOU WEREN'T IN A TUK-TUK,
YOU WERE IN A DRESS-DRESS.
YOU SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN THERE,
COMPLETE, FULL-ON MODELING.
DON'T THINK ABOUT THE TUK-TUK,
THINK ABOUT THE DRESS-DRESS.
AND THE POSE-POSE.
I REMEMBER
THINKING IN MY HEAD,
"DANIELLE, YOU'RE TRIPPING."
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
ON THE BEACH,
AND IT WAS SHOT BY
THE LOVELY NIGEL BARKER.
(laughter)
(Twiggy)
WELL, HER BODY LOOKS AMAZING.
(Nigel)
LOVELY.
YOU ARE DEFINITELY A LITTLE BIT
MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE OVER-SEXY SHOTS
THAN YOU ARE
WITH YOUR NATURAL BEAUTY.
VERY EASY WHEN YOU WEAR
SWIMSUITS TO THINK THAT
THAT KIND OF
"SPORTS ILLUSTRATED" LOOK
IS THE ONLY LOOK.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO GO
MORE WHAT THE CLIENT WANTS.
THE CLIENT WAS "ELLEgirl,"
AND THAT'S A LOT SOFTER,
A LOT MORE GENTLE,
A LOT YOUNGER.
I HAVE A LITTLE RULE.
MEN'S MAGAZINE, LEGS OPEN
LIKE THAT, STRAIGHT TO CAMERA.
WOMEN'S MAGAZINE,
TURN IT A LITTLE BIT.
SAME POSE,
TURN IT LIKE THIS.
MEN'S MAGAZINES,
ARCH THE BACK.
WOMEN'S MAGAZINES,
HUNCH THE BACK.
(Nigel)
YOU'RE MODELING TO WOMEN,
NOT TO MEN.
THANKS, DANIELLE.
UP NEXT IS SARA.
ALL RIGHT, SARA,
SO YOU WENT TO A GO-SEE,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST POLAROID
IN YOUR CLOTHES
FROM OFF THE STREET.
YOU WERE ONE STEP
FROM COVERING YOUR BODY
JUST WITH YOUR HANDS THERE
IN THE FRONT.
YOU LOOK VERY SHY
IN THE PICTURE.
GOOD CHOICE OF WORDS.
HERE'S YOUR SHOT
WITH THE DESIGNER'S CLOTHES ON.
THE PICTURE LOOKS
ALMOST TOO AMATEUR
FOR WHAT
YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE, THIS WHOLE COMPETITION,
IT LOOKS LIKE,
"HI, MY NAME IS SARA,
AND I WANT TO TRY OUT
FOR 'AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.'"
(Twiggy)
YOU LOOK LIKE A PRETTY GIRL,
BUT IT WOULDN'T POP OUT
IF YOU WERE LOOKING AT,
YOU KNOW, 20 GIRLS.
SARA, YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
AT THE BEACH
WITH MR. NIGEL BARKER,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
(Twiggy)
I WOULDN'T HAVE REALIZED
THAT WAS YOU.
YOU LOOK VERY, VERY DIFFERENT,
WHICH IS FANTASTIC.
YOUR FACE.
I THINK YOU WILL LOOK GREAT
IN THE SWIMSUIT AS WELL.
I REALLY FELT THE HARDSHIP
OF THE SHOOT.
YOU FOUND IT
VERY DIFFICULT TO RELAX.
DO YOU KNOW HOW TO SMILE
WITH YOUR EYES?
I THOUGHT SO.
WITHOUT MOVING YOUR LIPS?
WHY DON'T YOU TRY IT?
MM...
- MM-MMM.
- NO?
YOU HAVE TO THINK
OF SOMETHING FROM WITHIN,
AND SOMETHING THAT MAKES YOU
FEEL WARM,
LIKE, OKAY, AND NOW I'M--
I'M NOT SMILING WITH MY EYES
RIGHT NOW, I'M JUST GOING...
AND NOW I'M ABOUT TO SMILE
WITH MY EYES.
SEE THE DIFFERENCE?
IT'S SOMETHING FROM WITHIN.
AND THAT WAS THE THING.
EVEN IN THAT ENVIRONMENT,
WHICH WAS SO COMFORTABLE
AND BEAUTIFUL,
YOU JUST DIDN'T LET GO.
ALL RIGHT, SARA,
THANKS.
UP NEXT IS JADE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO SEE
YOUR POLAROID
IN YOUR NORMAL
CLOTHES FIRST.
(Nigel)
I THINK YOU HAD A VERY POSITIVE,
STRONG BODY LANGUAGE.
I THINK IT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT
TO HAVE A LITTLE SMILE
ON THE FACE.
IT'S A LITTLE TOUGH.
(Twiggy)
I AGREE WITH NIGEL.
A LITTLE SMILE,
A LITTLE BIT OF WARMTH,
'CAUSE YOU DO COME ACROSS,
AS YOU KNOW,
A LITTLE BIT
INTIMIDATING.
ALL RIGHT, AND THIS IS YOU
IN THE DESIGNERS' CLOTHES.
I LIKE THE SOFTNESS IN
YOUR FACE-- THAT'S MUCH NICER.
AND IT'S INTERESTING, 'CAUSE
YOU'RE NOT ACTUALLY SMILING,
BUT THERE'S A SOFTNESS.
THE INTIMIDATING FACTOR
IS GONE.
NONE OF THE GIRLS
WON THE GO-SEE CHALLENGE.
(Nigel laughing)
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED WITH
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
EVERYBODY FAILED
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS LATE.
AND, JADE, YOU WERE
THE MOST LATE.
IF IT WAS UP TO ME,
I WOULD HAVE RODE IN A CAB,
BECAUSE THOSE TUK--
HUT-HUTS,
HOOPTIE RIDE THAT I HAD?
IT WAS JUST LIKE, WHOO.
SO IF YOU WENT IN A TAXI,
YOU THINK YOU WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN THERE SOONER?
NOT NECESSARILY,
BUT I THINK THAT IT KIND OF--
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
MORE COMFORTABLE FOR MYSELF.
BUT AS A MODEL, IT'S--
A NEW MODEL, IT'S NOT ABOUT
BEING COMFORTABLE.
LIKE, I COULD SAY
THE SAME THING:
OH, IN PARIS, THE SUBWAY.
"OH, MY GOD,
IT'S SO HOT AND FUNKY,
AND THERE'S A MAN
TOUCHING MY BOOTY IN THE BACK."
AND I COULD HAVE SAID,
"OH, YEAH, A CAB IS EASIER,"
BUT A CAB'S NOT EASIER
WHEN YOU'RE A NEW MODEL
AND YOU AIN'T MAKING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS YET.
SO, JADE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE VERY NATURAL
ON THE BEACH.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
THAT'S GORGEOUS.
(J.)
I THINK THAT PICTURE'S
ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE.
- DO YOU?
- JUST KIDDING.
YOU JUST WANT TO BE
CONTROVERSIAL, DON'T YOU?
I REALLY LIKE THE FACE,
BEAUTIFUL FACE,
AND THE POSE IS
VERY BEAUTIFUL AS WELL.
THE ONE THING THAT I HAVE
TO CRITIQUE YOU ON
IS THE STIFFNESS.
THERE WERE THESE
BEAUTIFUL SHOTS OF YOU
WHEN YOU WERE SITTING
ON TOP OF THE BOAT,
AND IT WAS THIS HORIZON
AND KIND OF A PROFILE THING,
AND IT WAS ALMOST LIKE...
JUST A LITTLE RELAXING
WOULD HAVE MADE IT, LIKE,
EVEN BETTER THAN THIS.
NOW, GUYS, WHAT
YOU DON'T REALIZE
IS THIS BOAT WAS REARING
AND ROCKING
LIKE A STALLION HORSE.
WHAT WAS AMAZING WAS THAT YOU
MANAGED TO KEEP THAT SERENITY.
YOU IMPRESSED ME.
AFTER I WORKED WITH YOU,
I SAW A NEW JADE.
- THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IS JOANIE.
LOOK AT JOANIE LOOKING
ALL MODELLY TODAY.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
AND THE HAIR BACK, JOANIE?
I SEE THE NECK.
IT'S VERY MODELLY.
WELL, JOANIE,
YOU HAD GO-SEES.
HERE'S YOUR POLAROID
IN THE CLOTHES YOU WALKED IN
FROM THE STREET.
WHAT THIS POLAROID DOES SHOW,
JOANIE, IS THAT, BASICALLY,
YOU'VE GOT A GREAT FACE,
AND THE BONE STRUCTURE,
EVEN UNDER THE BLAST
OF A POLAROID CAMERA,
COMES OUT LOOKING FLAWLESS.
ALL RIGHT, JOANIE,
SO HERE IS YOUR PHOTO
IN THE CLIENT'S CLOTHES.
THE BODY JUST SEEMS A BIT,
LIKE, "DUH..."
(Tyra)
YOU NATURALLY STAND
LIKE THAT, JOANIE.
YOU STAND WITH YOUR HANDS
FORWARD, ALMOST LIKE,
- "HANDCUFF ME."
- VERY SIMIAN.
YOU HAVE TO STICK
THE CHEST OUT,
BUT NOT PORN-ISH,
BUT JUST STICK IT OUT
AND PUSH YOUR HANDS BACK
A LITTLE.
ALL RIGHT, JOANIE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH THE NOTED NIGEL BARKER,
AND HERE
IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
(Twiggy)
OH, I LOVE IT.
I THINK YOU LOOK FANTASTIC.
I'M SO IMPRESSED
WITH HOW YOU'VE CHANGED.
YOU'VE BECOME
A DIFFERENT GIRL.
WHEN I SAW HER NOTEBOOK,
I THOUGHT LIKE,
MAYBE SHE HAS NOT
MANY DIFFERENT LOOKS,
BUT THIS IS VERY BEAUTIFUL
AND VERY DIFFERENT.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
- AND YOU LOOK YOUNGER.
- THANKS, JOANIE.
ALL RIGHTY, NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WE'LL CALL YOU BACK
WHEN WE'VE MADE OUR DECISION.
IS IT GONNA BE EASY?
- MM-MMM.
I DON'T THINK SO, EITHER.
♪♪♪
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR US
TO DELIBERATE AND DECIDE
WHICH ONE OF THESE
YOUNG CHICKADEES
HAS TO GO HOME.
JOANIE.
(Twiggy)
THE PROOF IS IN THE PUDDING,
AND I THINK THAT'S
A GREAT PHOTOGRAPH.
I THINK SHE LOOKS WONDERFUL.
I LOVE JOANIE.
JOANIE'S
BIGGEST ISSUE IS THE FACT
THAT SHE ONLY REALLY
ONLY HAS ONE LOOK.
I MEAN, I WAS WITH HER
IN ALL KINDS OF SITUATIONS,
AND SHE STILL HAD ONE LOOK.
I WAS IMPRESSED
WITH JOANIE TODAY.
SHE PULLS THAT HAIR BACK,
AND SHE JUST BECAME EUROPEAN.
- DANIELLE.
- I LIKE HER FACE,
BUT I DON'T LIKE THIS POSE.
I THINK SHE LOOKS LOVELY HERE,
OTHER THAN THE SLIGHTLY,
YOU KNOW,
PROVOCATIVE POSE.
THIS IS NOT FASHION
ON THE BEACH.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE,
IF YOU'RE A BOY.
AND I'M STILL CONCERNED
ABOUT HER SPEECH.
SHE CANNOT DO A COVERGIRL
COMMERCIAL SPEAKING LIKE THAT.
- SARA.
- THIS PHOTO IS NICE,
AND SHE'S GOT A GREAT BODY.
YES, YOU KNOW,
I LOVE TALL GIRLS.
I'D RATHER HAVE A TALL
GIRL THAN A SHORT GIRL,
BUT IN THE END, I MEAN,
WE NEED A GIRL
THAT CAN FIT EVERYTHING,
AND SHE MAY NOT BE THE GIRL.
SARA HAS A GREAT BODY
FOR SWIMWEAR.
SHE'S LEARNING,
SHE'S MOVING, SHE'S CHANGING,
AND SHE'S
AN INTERESTING GIRL.
JADE.
WHEN SHE CAME TO MY GO-SEE,
SHE WASN'T REALLY SMILEY.
SHE LOOKED UPSET,
SHE LOOKED TIRED.
I JUST DON'T LIKE
HER ATTITUDE.
SHE'S ALWAYS ON THE DEFENSIVE,
IT'S NEVER HER FAULT,
SHE'S NEVER WRONG.
AND IT DRIVES ME NUTS.
WELL, THE THING IS
IS THAT JADE KNOWS
HOW TO MODEL,
AND THAT'S INVALUABLE.
THIS IS WHY SHE'S STILL HERE,
GUYS.
'CAUSE EVERY WEEK,
SHE DOES ACTUALLY COME UP
WITH A GREAT SHOT.
WHO SHOULD GO HOME?
THAT GIRL SHOULD GO HOME.
TWIGGY?
HER,
SHOULD GO HOME.
HER SHOULD GO HOME?
OH, THAT DOESN'T MAKE--
(laughter)
SHE BEEN AROUND
TOO MANY BLACK FOLKS.
FOUR BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
THREE PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE THREE OF YOU
THAT WILL STILL
BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
JOANIE.
YOU LOOK ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL
TODAY, LIKE A REAL MODEL.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
JADE.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY,
FOR BELIEVING IN ME,
AND YOU AS WELL, TYRA.
JADE, YOU KEEP
SAYING THAT EVERY WEEK.
YOU SAY,
"THANKS FOR BELIEVING IN ME,
THANKS FOR
BELIEVING IN ME."
IT'S NOT JUST BELIEVING IN YOU,
IT'S YOU PRODUCING.
THIS PICTURE'S
A HUGE IMPROVEMENT.
IT'S SO SOFT.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL DANIELLE AND SARA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
♪♪♪
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO
REPRESENTS THE GIRL
THAT WILL STILL
BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOTEL
AND FLY HOME.
SARA, THE JUDGES LOOK AT YOU
AS THE MOST IMPROVED GIRL HERE.
DANIELLE TOOK BEAUTIFUL
PICTURES FROM THE START.
SO DID JOANIE...
SO DID JADE.
BUT THE REASON YOU'RE STILL
IN THIS COMPETITION
IS BECAUSE
YOU'VE PROGRESSED.
THAT'S WHAT THIS COMPETITION
IS ABOUT.
IT'S ABOUT STARTING SOMEWHERE
AND THEN PROGRESSING.
IT'S NOT ABOUT STARTING STRONG,
IT'S ABOUT IMPROVING.
BUT THE JUDGES ARE NOW SAYING,
"HAS SHE IMPROVED ENOUGH?"
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH THAT
AN "A" FOR EFFORT CAN GIVE YOU.
DANIELLE, THE JUDGES STILL
STRUGGLE WITH YOUR SPEECH.
THE WINNER OF THIS COMPETITION
HAS TO BE A COVERGIRL MODEL.
SHE HAS TO BE ARTICULATE,
SHE HAS TO SPEAK ELOQUENTLY.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
THE GIRL THAT'S
IMPROVED SO MUCH,
BUT MAY HAVE REACHED
HER STARS?
OR THE GIRL THAT
TAKES BEAUTIFUL PICTURES,
BUT THE JUDGES DON'T TRUST
WHEN SHE OPENS HER MOUTH?
DANIELLE.
DANIELLE, ACCENTS ARE BEAUTIFUL
BECAUSE THEY SHOW THE WORLD
WHERE WE COME FROM,
BUT AS A MODEL,
YOU GOTTA LEARN TO TURN IT ON
AND TURN IT OFF.
YOU HAVE TO PRACTICE SPEAKING.
EVERY TIME YOU OPEN
YOUR MOUTH,
TRY TO SPEAK
LIKE A COVER GIRL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
GOOD-BYE.
THANK YOU.
YOU SHOULD BE PROUD.
YOU STARTED NOT KNOWING
WHAT THE HELL YOU WERE DOING.
I'M STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE IT OUT,
BUT I THINK
I'M GETTING IT.
YEAH, BUT YOU'RE
GETTING THERE.
- THANK YOU.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
♪♪♪
I THINK THAT PEOPLE QUESTIONED
MY DESIRE TO BE HERE.
YOU KNOW, IT SOUNDS BAD,
I WAS FOUND IN A MALL,
BUT MODELING IS KIND OF--
IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I'VE NEVER DONE BEFORE,
AND IT'S BEEN SOMETHING
KIND OF CREATIVE
AND ARTISTIC
THAT ALLOWED ME TO KIND OF
SHOW DIFFERENT SIDES
OF MYSELF.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO PICK OUT
A CUTE SHIRT AT THE MALL,
AND SINCE THEN, I'VE GOTTEN
TO DO SO MANY THINGS.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
IT'S ALL COME DOWN
TO OUR TOP THREE.
TWO WILL MAKE IT PAST
A CHALLENGING
COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL.
- COVERGIRL.
- THEIR MOST PLASTIC LASH--
CUT.
- CUT.
- WHAT IS WRONG WITH ME?
AND FACE OFF ON OUR
MOST EXOTIC RUNWAY EVER.
THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
FIND OUT WHO
ON OUR SEASON FINALE.
♪♪♪
♪ I WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ I WANNA BE ON TOP ♪♪